what do you think you need to like watch
an entire show to review it because like
who is this i went through this uh
some critters went through i know what
you're talking about yeah some critics
your movie starts yeah yeah your movie
starts right you uh watch all the movies
to the end because you'd get but i think
if you drop a show like i feel like if
you're being if you're giving it praise
i feel like you can't give it praise and
only have watched half that yeah yeah
yeah that's like that doesn't make any
sense if you if you drop a show it's got
to be an a normally a negative review
where do you all stand on that like is
like the whole can you review a movie or
a show without having watched if the
movie is so bad or boring or uninspired
and you're halfway through it i think
it's totally valid to be like listen
i've got a bunch of other movies to
watch yeah this clearly isn't gonna you
know it's already been so bad in the
first 50 minutes yeah how is it gonna
turn it all around but here's the
question in a reviewing capacity though
as a viewer i think of course yeah you
don't have to watch everything yeah yeah
yeah but if you're gonna definitively be
like this movie is
bad or this movie is good but you don't
watch the whole thing do you think
that's valid if your job is a movie
review i think it's valid you're
watching so many movies yeah i mean i
mean it depends on like i think it
depends on like a case-by-case basis but
like at the end of the day if a piece of
media is so
bad that a reviewer cannot finish it you
know that eve even if it gets better
then
powerful nominations yeah
shut the [ __ ] up
uh if if if like if an anime is bad up
to a certain point then you like you got
to you got to like
you got to admit that there is something
about the show that
a lot of people would not be able to get
through because it is bad but
in a reviewing capacity
see i completely
disagree i think not with you but yeah
with you i think you disagree with me
yeah no it's fine we already did
i think if you're going to definitively
review something you have to watch the
whole thing i think that's the that's
the minimum you have to do especially
when it's a tv series as well i feel
like yeah like because it can very
quickly change and turn and it's a
moment we brought up
right and that like
you know i cannot i could not
authoritatively authoritatively be like
clinette is bad all the way through or
it's just bad because when i finally sat
down and watched and like the last 11
episodes right are quite good but i
can't counterpoint then because i go
okay sure do you think you need to watch
all of one piece in order to be able to
review it right like there's some shows
where the length is so absurd yeah like
it would be completely unrealistic to
expect like a reviewer who's their job
to get through all of this media yeah so
imagine how much you would [ __ ] hate
your job if you were like i have to
review one person and that's why i
stopped reviewing anime well i think
with one piece you're not gonna
no no one is gonna be like i'm gonna
review
all of it as a whole yeah if you're
reviewing one piece you're going like
episode by episode or at least arc by
arc yeah because like i feel like you
need to watch enough of something to at
least get like a like a taste or a
feeling about what this show is about
and what it can achieve because like to
me if i hear someone like judge one
piece i like i ask okay how far have you
gotten right like if someone drops it in
like the first few arcs i'm just like
well you didn't even scratch the surface
into what one piece can do if they watch
until alabaster they still don't like it
i'm like okay i understand maybe one
piece just isn't for you at that point i
think it's i think it's all about like
what percentage of the overall show you
actually consume right because it's like
you know if you yeah as you said with
the one piece thing if you only watched
like up until the alabaster arc you know
in retrospect that's a very small
percentage of the show that's only a
bite size so
we still have to be specific though on
reviewing capacity yeah yeah yeah just
casual viewing of course no one has to
watch all of one piece to be like it's
not for me yeah yeah yeah if you're just
watching like i'm not really into it
like yeah that's fair yeah yeah and i
often tell people i say kind of like
what you said if you watch arlong park
and after that still don't give a [ __ ]
yeah then i don't think it's gonna work
for you yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly
for me it's like okay let's say
like you said there's a casual view it
doesn't matter if you drop it right yeah
but for me as well it's like if the
reviewer also feels the same way where
he's like i'm cutting out here i'm like
okay that's something i can kind of
relate to because i wouldn't i wouldn't
sit through it and just dredge through
it just because yeah i have to i feel
like i have to finish it it's gonna
depend on the context of what the
reviewer is doing right if the reviewer
is like if there's someone just asking
what do you think about one piece it's
like oh i watched up to this point it
wasn't for me yeah that's fine but if
you're putting out like a video like
is one piece
good or bad or whatever like such a
loaded question as well
and also you know bringing in like a
long show like one piece yeah then
you're gonna have some exceptions yeah
yeah yeah
that would be something you would expect
to be reviewed in chunks yeah right but
if it's a 12 episode show then i think
or even like a two core like watch the
whole thing yeah yeah yeah and a movie
in sp in particular it's like
i do
you should
finish it before you review it i mean
you can you can stop you know as a
viewer but if you're reviewing it if
it's a movie yeah i i do think you
should i don't know i i i can only
imagine the life of a movie reviewer as
hell because you you have to watch
most films are mediocre like that yeah
right yeah
like think about all the movies that
came out last year and and how many of
them remember that's true of like every
piece of media right truth
[Music]
i would not expect any insane human to
sit through all of these movies and then
be like yeah this is this is this was
really really bad but i just finished it
because to me it's like if the first
half was super [ __ ] but it got amazing
in the second half it would still lose
marks or points in your head for having
the really [ __ ] first half yeah i i i
dropped 86 everyone got really annoyed
that i didn't like 86. i just thought it
was so boring and i watched nine
episodes nine episodes of the show yeah
that is so much time but you're not
reviewing it you're just viewing it no i
know yeah but i mean i i i i could say
but he gave his opinion on trash taste
therefore he's a reviewer
i said i said it was just boring and i
didn't enjoy it and i was nine episodes
i mean listen i watched one episode of
no game no life thought it was dog [ __ ]
and stopped watching so you know i'm
with you like
i do intend to sit down and watch it at
some point and actually watch it but as
a casual viewer i was like i don't like
this at all but like i think um it's a
good show yeah yeah
even with them
the movie was [ __ ] boring but the the
tv series was pretty good okay yeah i
think also some shows are just not for
me yeah yeah yeah
yeah um
but yeah i think with the movie i mean i
don't know i do board game reviews right
yeah played a lot of [ __ ] games yeah and
those take even longer than movies some
games some games take like six hours to
play and you didn't you're done you're
like that was
throughout
horrible
i guess for me if it's like if i'm gonna
review something yeah you wanna i have
to be like because you know there can be
aspects near the end sometimes you watch
a movie and you're like the last 30
minutes
it got really interesting yeah yeah yeah
and vice versa i guess that's why you
with reviewers it's kind of like you
know you got to find the reviewer that
you kind of have the similar
yeah look on movies or media yeah and
for me i'm like i like it with my
reviewers like this movie was so [ __ ] i
had to drop it 50 minutes in even though
it's my job to finish this it's that bad
that i didn't yeah well yeah when it's
that bad but like i think there's a lot
of like anime especially where it's like
yeah the first half or you know the
first couple of episodes is like really
[ __ ] a weak start right or and but
you know it could have an ending that's
like surprisingly good and i i feel with
anime there's a lot more where it's vice
versa where the start is really really
strong
and then the ending is just dog [ __ ]
like dead man wonderland's like a great
example where it's like first couple of
episodes of [ __ ] like oh my god this
is insane and then it was just dog [ __ ]
near the end right but like you wouldn't
have known that yeah in the manga as
well right but like you wouldn't have
known that if you didn't stick through
to the end yeah i mean that's like most
seasonal anime nowadays yeah you watched
the first three episodes and like damn
this [ __ ] slash they put all the
effort into the first three yeah yeah
exactly right it's just because of the
way that they make manga right like you
have to have the good initial sales they
got to hook you in yeah yeah yeah the
first few chapters and then they're like
oh [ __ ] we didn't plan this for our
heads yeah yeah yeah but like clan ed
right i would never be like i would
never
judge someone to be like that's [ __ ]
up they were like clan i was so boring i
couldn't make it after story no i
totally i think that is very fair it's
unreasonable to be like you have to
watch 25 episodes before it gets good
well same with stein's [ __ ] right
like
you know it's like oh the first 11
episodes are boring as [ __ ] and i'm like
yeah i kind of agree with that but like
you know the second half is [ __ ]
incredible yeah i think bottom line it's
like
it just really depends on you know for
casual viewers doesn't matter yeah
reviewers it's gonna your mileage is
gonna vary i think so isn't it weird now
that saying like you have to just like
suffer through 25 episodes and that just
feels so long but like back in the day i
remember i would gladly watch like two
seasons of a show like in order before
it gets good you know that was just like
okay easy easy 50 episodes of one piece
until along park that's that's yeah i
can get easier in the [ __ ] day 50
episodes until our longbow yeah yeah
okay yeah the the animation is very
dramatic anime of one piece is uh is is
awful which is why you're saying the dbc
right and like all those shows back then
yeah yeah yeah